[Musique]
et avec nous un hadjar et man army lente
militante associative et fondatrice de
la brigade des mers nicolas glières
enseignants membres des styles rouge
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors comment
est ce que vous vous accueillez
l'initiative des pouvoirs publics avec
ce rapport de pierre aubin pour
promouvoir justement la laïcité dans les
écoles 1 à 10 heures et magna alors
j'irai city ça fait des années qu'on
nous parle de toute façon et je pense
que c'est pas j'aimerais savoir qui va
former les formateurs parce que moi même
j'ai participé à une formation sur la
laïcité
et franchement je vous avoue que je suis
sorti de là bas j'ai rien compris à part
me dire qu'il fallait tolérante et qu'il
fallait pas provoquer tout ça quand je
suis sorti de là bas on n'a pas répondu
à mes questions et la laïcité dans les
établissements scolaires ben moi j'avais
déjà travaillé à une occasion nationale
il dit aux enseignants de gérer mais à
un moment donné en hausse à suis pas je
pense qu'il faudrait plus fort mais les
yeux certains chefs d'établissement
il faudrait plus fort mais le rectorat
que de former les enseignants
je pense dans la jean pierre aubin ça
rapporte de jean pierre robin et colas
glières qu'en pensez vous effectivement
je suis parfaitement d'accord est ce que
nadia raider est maintenant bien de dire
ce sont les chefs d'établissements les
inspecteurs qui devrait plutôt être
formés à ce sujet là ce sont des gens
souvent sans conviction comme les
membres du rectorat des politiques
concrètement qui reste en place qui aux
annonces couleurs zidane au nez et qui
nous font ensuite la messe c'est le cas
de le dire ici je vous rappelle quand
même c'est l'essentiel
en 2011 et en 2014 les inspecteurs ses
chers jeunes qui ne font plus court
parfois depuis 30 ans ou expliqué qu'il
fallait faire disparaître le xviiie
siècle des programmes ont essayé de le
faire disparaître des programmes
pourquoi le 18e pourquoi les lumières
parce que c'était polémique parce que ça
pouvait faire des vagues
le ministère dans son pas de vagues et
constant voilà ce qu'ils ont fait ce
sont les mêmes gens qui vont maintenant
vouloir nous former vouloir nous
expliquer comment faire la laïcité à
l'école je rappelle aussi que ce sont
les mêmes ce qu'ils font ce rapport jean
patrick font un rapport à jean pierre
aubin mais ceux qui vont nous former
ceux qui vont créer cette formation sont
ceux qui ont abandonné samuel pâti à son
sort
ce sont ceux qui n'ont parfois même
menacés alors qu'il ne faisait que son
travail
et puis mettre une formation en place
par rapport à la laïcité c'est faire
croire que samuel pâtit été nul et c'est
pour ça qu'il a été tué concrètement
qu'il a été assassiné
c'est absolument pas digne donc oui face
est une absurdité cette formation en
plus à risque d'être très mauvaise passe
que les formations éducation nationale
sont lamentables je peux vous le dire
pour ce que j'ai vécu
pour tout ce que les collègues livrent
des témoignages sur les styles aux joues
roses mais je vous propose avec nadia
ramana de regarder ce sondage ifop du 6
janvier 2021 qui dresse justement un
état des lieux
40 % des professeurs interrogés
affirment avoir eu affaire à des
incidents liés à la contestation du
principe de laïcité dans l'assiette 53 %
des enseignants interrogés ont observé
de la part des élèves au moins une fois
des formes de contestation au nom deux
d'une religion c'est un sondage qui est
daté de janvier 2001 mais depuis il ya
eu les attentats de il ya eu les
attentats à bien avant cela de 2015
avant on sait que la situation était
délicate
on en a pris vraiment conscience
beaucoup plus après l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit il ya eu déjà un précédent
rapport obin c'est en 2004 est ce que
vous considérez que l'éducation a fermé
les yeux jusqu'ici nadia et magna alors
moi tous les revenus sur les sondages et
moi j'aime les sondés on n'a jamais j'ai
demandé aux gens des quartiers ils ont
jamais été son avis alors moi j'ai un
problème avec des sondages surtout
concernant la laïcité parce que je pense
qu'il ya plus de 40%
bien que dans une ville et après moi je
pense que alors j'ai omis la question
vous avez pensé que non il ya eu des
précédents
rieumes par exemple est ce que les uns
question a fermé les yeux
il ya un il ya aussi le fameux
accommodements qu'ont fait certains
chefs d'établissement vais vous donner
un exemple j'ai travaillé dans un
collège en seine saint denis et un
moment donné
remise des livres et on avait
effectivement de jeune fille qui était
voilée et qu'effectivement dans les
établissements scolaires on va retirer
notre foulard et moi j'étais à la halle
à l'accueil avec un collègue et je vous
dis à ces jeunes filles retirer votre
foulard et le chef d'établissement qui
est mon responsable dit non aux médias
laisse tomber c'est que la remise des
livres et il ya plein d'exemples comme
c'est en fin de compte c'est les
accommodements qu'on laisse landaise au
nom de soi disant vivre ensemble et tout
ce qu'on veut et un moment donné ça a
dérapé
effectivement aujourd'hui la laïcité
dans les écoles je pense que c'est de
toute façon c'est la france qui est laïc
c'est comme si quand c'est une formation
pour comment ne pas voler la cité existe
un moment donné je voulais savoir qui
des ça dérange qui la laïcité je ne
comprends pas ça dérange qui exactement
est-ce que dès qu'on parle de laïcité on
nous traite de fachos d'intégristes tout
de suite les grands mots alors je
voulais savoir aujourd'hui notre
recherche éducation nationale notre
ministre je voulais lui poser une
question
je serai curieuse qui va former donc les
enseignants ou le faux pas mais aussi de
la vie scolaire parce que dans leur
établissement scolaire
y a pas que des enseignes à la vie
scolaire et à l'administration qui m'a
formé
c'est comment on va les former et quels
sont les modules effectivement est ce
qu'on va nous donner des modules sur
l'histoire de france est ce qu'on va
nous dire ni apprenez le coran ou où
l'on va dire peut-être la bigue l'autre
presque effectivement aujourd'hui ça
veut dire quoi la laïcité parce qu'on a
peur d'en parler et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète moi aujourd'hui
comme vous avez enseigné la laïcité plus
qu'un moment de numidie surtout ne font
pas leur parler surtout faut pas les
contrarier quand je dis nous le dira
mais contrarié ça veut dire justement
ceux qui ne respectent pas la laïcité
faux pas avec mon travail et si les
contrarier vous êtes provocateur c'est
vous qui mettez le monde en 2008 dans le
fait qu'en dix ans fait un moment donné
je pense qu' il soit arrêter
l'hypocrisie
un moment donné écoles et la vic la
france est un pays laïc
les enseignants sont importantes et va
former les enseignants des collèges lien
vous avez une idée
vous avez déjà des échos ce sera leur
prochain en principe dans l'éducation
nationale ce sont des enseignants
l'arbre qui sont désolés d'humour c'est
un mot grossier mais c'est le mot qui
convient en fait des inspecteurs vont
repérer qui parmi les enseignants sont
les plus ardents les plus obéissants les
plus dociles et ils vont leur dire de
faire la messe mais pas vous le dire
autrement ça se passe toujours comme ça
c'est comme ça on devient inspecteur ce
qu'ils valent concours il faut quand
même rappeler aussi ça pour devenir
inspecteur n'y a aucun concours
c'est une espèce de cooptation entre
pairs
donc on prend les plus l'arbre et puis
on les fait monter dans la hiérarchie
c'est exactement pareil là on va avoir
la même chose donc des gens pas
forcément compétents pas forcément
convaincu est-ce qu'il faut aussi il ya
un tel boucan même très fort à ce sujet
là parmi les enseignants il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont plus de conviction non
plus en plus faut être honnête on va pas
non plus bas je pense qu'il faut que
tout le monde se regarde un peu face à
nicolas claire puisque vous parlez de
deux des sujets tabous il ya il ya pour
poursuivre encore sur la situation
alarmante au sein de l'enseignement
on va regarder justement cette
infographie qui montrent qu'ils parlent
justement qui évoque l' autocensure
regardez l'autocensure des enseignants
qui craignent de dire quelque chose qui
pourrait créer une altercation atteint
des proportions inquiétantes depuis
l'assassinât de samuel pâti de nombreux
chefs d'établissement et de directeurs
d'école m'ont parlé de ce phénomène
selon les enseignants ont peur mais ne
disent rien
nicolas glières je reviens vers vous on
va vous avez vous allez réagir un nadhir
hamada mais est ce que cette peur là
elle elle vous parle il n'y a pas
d'autre issue
l'autocensure abbas y avoir des
convictions se battre faire avoir du
courage croire en ce qu'on fait en fait
quand on est enseignant on est laïque
puisqu'on est là pour apprendre aux
élèves l'esprit critique
la laïcité c'est l'essence même de
l'esprit critique à mon sens puisqu'elle
permet de vivre ensemble de tous
elle ne met aucune religion en haut elle
l'aimé tout sous les lois de la
république et en fait elle permet à
toulouse de cohabiter c'est ça qui est
magnifique
cet idéal c'est pas qu'un vide et al
elle a marché elle a fonctionné
pourquoi ne fonctionnerait pas le plus
parce qu'elle dérange certains vous
l'avez très bien dit tout à l'heure la
dir est mana elle dérange qui les
intégristes et puis et puis certains
autres aussi qui s'accommode des
trotskistes certains élus de tous bords
au passage aux airs on a eu des l'udf
s'arrangea très bien notamment vers
trappe je crois enfin voilà on a on a
vraiment un lâche 1,1 laisser faire au
niveau de la laïcité on ne la suis plus
on ne la protège peut alors qu'elle est
un trésor
elle permet à tous d'être vient d'être
heureux elle permet aux élèves de mieux
apprendre aussi parce qu'elles ouvrent
leurs esprits ça n'empêche pas d'être
croyant d'être laïc on peut tout à fait
faire respecter la laïcité ne pas
imposer sa religion de façon
ostentatoire ou prosélyte la vivre
discrètement pourquoi devrait-elle est
uniquement agressive visible oppressif
concrètement ça c'est quelque chose qui
a changé quand j'étais élève
pour ma part je pense que vous serez
pareil c'était pas comme ça donc il n'y
a pas de raison que cela change d'autant
plus que c'est un changement négatif
vous comprenez nazaire et magna qu'on en
arrive à photos censurées dans l'école
de la république
alors moi je ne comprends pas qu'on
arrive parce qu'on est dans un pays de
liberté d'expression tout ça ce qui est
pire les gens ont peur est pire que ça
les gens sont lâches parce
qu'effectivement on voit plusieurs fois
j'ai été menacé par rapport à mon combat
parce que justement à l'éducation
nationale non seulement on n'est pas
soutenue et non seulement vous fait vous
fait comprendre que vous avez été trop
loin vous avez dépassé les bornes
un moment donné de nuon vous recadre
alors c'est plus que la peur parce que
c'est la lâcheté et puis après les
autres ils ont profil losc
automatiquement il ya un problème je
voudrais dire aussi c'est devenue
politisée
quand l'éducation nationale et les
écoles deviennent politisé par exemple
dans certains quartiers quand vous avez
le directeur d'école certains pas tous
attention on a des très bons enseignants
j'ai rien à dire mais quand vous avez un
directeur d'école qui fait de la
politique
au lieu de faire son travail des
directeurs il est là en train de donner
des tracts du matin au soir en disant
l'islam
by par ci islamophobie par la pomme en
libye quel jeu pauvre un moment donné il
faut effectivement sanctionner les
responsables et responsable tout irait
mieux
ce sont les inspecteurs se sont bien sûr
notre ministère et les chefs
d'établissement qui ne font pas leur
travail a pas défendre les autres comme
je dis les autres qui sont contre nous
et ben non
et parce qu'en fait quand ils sont enfin
de commencer avec la caserne des troupes
en danger des contenus sont nombreux
nous on est quelques on va dire d'un
pour cent quand vous parlez de l'air
fait aussi écraser les 80 % ils sont
soutenus par les politiques par le
ministère et puis voilà on va commencer
comme si con funk honteux c'est une
question morale - entre guillemets mais
quand vous parlez de l'acheter on peut
aussi comprendre qu'à une certaine peur
quand même à hull à l'assassinât de sa
mère pattie nicolas glières mais la peur
je la comprends cela dit comment dire il
ne faut pas arriver jusqu'au port où on
a peur et pour ça il faudra des
convictions il faut se battre
or les gens laissent faire c'est à dire
que c'est là où ils sont lâches y
compris des collègues en fait ils ont
baissé les bras et à l'entendre à peu
près c'est là où est le problème il ne
les aurait pas baissé tout se passerait
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui je pense il y
eu énormément de renoncement je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de la disparition
l'air de rien du xviiie siècle dont les
programmes en 2011 2014
écoutez bien 2011 c'est un gouvernement
de droite
lr les républicains l'ump à l'époque
2014 c'est le ps donc c'est assez
étonnant quand même que ce soit l heure
où le ps au pouvoir dans l'éducation
nationale on supprime tout ce qui va
gêner les intégristes c'est quand même
un problème ensuite c'est facile de
fanfaronner de parler sécurité
c'est assez rigolo quand même nous
avancerons pas ça drôle en soir en 16es
sert uniquement sur ses rares ballons
arrivent à ce point là sont au censurer
ce que c'est rattrapable
on a dit aravane n'a alors c'est
rattrapable lui faut un courage et un
moment donné il faut sanctionner comme
je disais je me répète les
bon ça parce qu'à un moment donné on
peut pas parce que vise à lui déjà des
jeux des élèves déjà qu'ils vont grandir
dans un espèce de de pouvoir
effectivement on va pas faire d'eux de
bons citoyens qui vont respecter
certaines règles de notre pays et en
allemand ça fait ça met en danger les
enseignants et le petit personnel si je
peux me permettre de parler comme ça
maintenant on donnait six 6 mois
j'aurais dit je vais vous dire quelque
chose l'étranger les coûts s'il allait
nouvelle présidentielle
peu importe le président à la base mois
qu'on va mais je vous dis reçoit enlève
le problème maintenant tout de suite et
on a un courage politique courageux dans
tous les domaines soit on va laisser
faire et je peux vous dire dans cinq ans
malheureusement j'ai peur moi qui ai sur
les quartiers moi qui parle avec les
familles moi qui suit les élèves
je peux vous dire que j'ai autour de moi
plus de personnes radicaliser qu'il ya
cinq ans quand j'ai créé la brigade des
mers genou on se retrouve aujourd'hui
franchement on sait plus quoi faire
parce qu'on est lâché et puis on a toqué
à toutes les portes je peux vous dire
j'ai vu tous les ministères j'ai vu
presque tous les élus de droite comme de
gauche et je peux vous dire que ce qui
arrive c'est encore pire qu est-ce qu il
y avait quand même les attentats de
charlie à 5 ans c'est encore pire et je
peux vous dire quand j'ai dit pire je
suis je je fais attention mais je peux
vous dire moi je suis très très très
pessimiste nicolas guillet voilà ce
qu'on peut faire par rapport à pour
cette situation je pense qu'il faut
reprendre la laïcité à bout de bras il
faut arrêter d'avoir peur justement de
ce sujet il faut faire des débats avec
les élèves il faut faire des débats avec
ses classes il faut être certain d'avoir
le soutien de sa direction des
inspecteurs je pense que vous aurez
compris on est d'accord tous les deux
c'est très rarement le cas au contraire
on peut même être sanctionnés quand on
fait son boulot voire assassinés ça
c'est autre chose il faut rester dans la
lutte
c'est une lutte de tous les jours c'est
une lutte de république ainsi une lutte
de laïcs
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel former
les jeunes à l'esprit civique à la
laïcité au respect de l'autre et de sa
pensée
l'autre a le droit de ne pas être
croyant l'autre a le droit de trouver
que votre croyance est amusante comme la
mythologie grecque était amusante c'est
pas grave si on est réellement croyants
et sincèrement croyants où est le
problème on n'a pas besoin de l'aval des
ont juste
nicolas glières le jean pierre aubin
dans l'ancien inspecteur général de
l'éducation nationale qui est l'auteur
du rapport s'est exprimé sur les
propositions qu'il a émises dans ce
rapport sur rmc aujourd'hui il y avait
qu une proposition qui retient
l'attention regarder le ministre
souhaite enclencher un processus
c'est-à-dire ont créé quelque chose dans
une réalité institutionnelle qui devra
se développer par la suite il faut
instituer un nouveau dispositif de
formation à travers des certifications
sur la laïcité qu'on pourra accorder aux
étudiants aux professeurs qui ont suivi
un certain nombre de stages alors des
certifications sur la laïcité accordés
aux étudiants et aux professeurs votre
avis là-dessus à commencer par von arx
vous savez moi personnellement je pense
pas que c'est ça qui va changer parce
qu'on a fédéré et comment s'appelle des
référents laïcité dans les salles de
sport et autres savez celui qui va faire
une formation par rapport à ce qu'on a
pu dire à l'extérieur et autour moi je
pense que c'est ces bas niveau après je
pense pourquoi pas pour certains mais un
moment là on est dans l'urgence c'est
pas un certificat sur un truc ils
arrivent à contourner c'est toujours la
durée je pense que la laïcité devrait
être enseignée comme matières comme la
philo kong l'histoire comme tueur devant
rajouter comme une matière et il
faudrait aussi impliquer les parents
impliqués les familles parce
qu'effectivement vous avez un jeune on
va lui parler de la laïcité à l'école
et quant à l'extérieur sur certaines
familles où tout son entourage on va
nous dire tout le contraire comment
voulez vous qu'un enfant puisse
comprendre
je pense qu'il faut déjà formé les
maires certains aiguë certains élus de
la république qui pour moi sont aussi
responsables ils sont formés tout le
monde il faut pas fermer aux enseignants
de ce qu'on dit on va former les
enseignants et comme disait tout à
l'heure monsieur qui veut fort mythiques
au monde
moi je voudrais savoir les modeuses
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la formation
j'ai par magic fait des formations sur
la laïcité je peux dire quand je suis
sorti de là bas j'ai dit mais ils ont
bien compris et pourtant c'était
soi-disant des intellectuels
alors je suis sorti de là bas turello
sur le contenu des déformations nicolas
glisse sur la sortie des certifications
sur la laïcité qu'est ce que vous en
pensez et par ailleurs pour terminer il
va falloir appliquer aussi les ce que ce
qui va être enseignée l'ordre justement
de 2 c de ce plan de formation sur
quatre ans est ce qu'on en a les joues
17 alors mais ça va être fait par qui ça
va être fait comment avoir un papier qui
disent oui au pays au pied je suis
expert laïcité ne suffit pas il faut la
vivre
il faut en avoir été convaincus depuis
longtemps et puis les autres choses il
faut aussi le combat des stylos rouges
ces salaires moyens respect c'est pas
pour rien on n'embauche pas des gens qui
ont des convictions des gens de qualité
des gens qui ont une bonne formation
intellectuelle
si on les fait fuir avec des salaires
des boutons donc tout est lié si vous
voulez je sais vraiment pas une
cacahuète de ma part mais on n'empêchera
pas des bons profs des preuves solides
exigeons avec un bon bagage intellectuel
on les paye un peu plus que le smic
voilà ça ça fait partie des choses nadia
rehman a en tout cas je suis vraiment
très très heureux de parler avec vous et
je je je tiens vraiment à vous à vous
remercier pour votre combat il est
remarquable j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
vous depuis longtemps je ne vous le dire
en face donc faire au poids on pourra
pas faire autrement en prenant le sujet
à bras le corps dont l'école mais sans
l'inspecteur allen qui nous soutiennent
mais qui nous laisse tranquille on sait
mieux gérer que ils sont ils ne sont pas
au contact du terrain
ils sont dans l'idéologie les
inspecteurs sont dans l'idéologie de
ministères dans l'idéologie que ce soit
une idéologie ou une autre peu importe
il faut pas d'idéologie ici il faut du
concret il faut du pratique il faut
s'occuper de nos élèves
les former l'esprit critique et pour
avoir de l'esprit critique faut arrêter
que la hiérarchie noire celle est ce que
des gens harceler qui n'ont pas parlé ne
peuvent pas avoir d'esprit critique non
plus donc voila tout se tient tout se
recoupe est en fait ce ministère marche
mal dont il ne peut pas nous former à
quoi que ce soit de positif tant qu'ils
fonctionnent comme il fonctionne le pad
vague est toujours en cours monsieur
blanc coeur à une politique
catastrophique dans l'éducation depuis
quatre ans ils vont qu'il dégage
alors on a dit aman a justement pour
pointer les responsabilités
cette situation actuelle parmi les
enseignants au sein de l'éducation
nationale
vous pointez qui quelles responsabilités
ben moi je vais effectivement le east et
parce que c'est les municipaux qui se
consomme qui sont quand même responsable
il faut pas oublier il se compare deux
ministères ont par l'enseignant est ce
qu'on part des enseignants du collège du
premier degré du second degré où la
maternelle parce que je pense qu'il faut
effectivement il faut définir on va
former les enseignants de la maternelle
parce que je pense qu'il faut commencer
de la maternelle mais je pense moi c'est
mon avis en tant que travailleuse
sociale
je pense si on a toutes parts les
parents et certains parents on les
connaît on sait qui est qui et avec
justement une attestation je sais pas
comment parler ça hein maman 2000 comme
je dis je redis ça dérange qui la
laïcité a votre avis
ça dérange pas je passe une grande
majorité des enseignants ça dérange pas
certaine ça dérange qui justement si
aujourd'hui on n'applique pas les
familles et les travailleurs sociaux et
tous ceux qui travaillent autour du
public
eh ben on à pois avec toute la volonté
du monde n'oublie pas on ne vieillit pas
pardon on a une jeunesse à protéger je
dis bien à protéger et si nous les
adultes on assume
moi j'ai des jeunes qu'ils disent oui
mais je peux pas parce qu'on part sous
le monde de laïcité d'assimilation dit
mais comment tu veux que je fasse si
j'ai un merck du maître de maths du
premier descend du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
il me dit que je suis musulman je ne
suis que musulmans aussi son responsable
et je pense que moi j'en veux énormément
aux inspecteurs parce que j'ai travailé
l'éducation nationale j'essayais de
mettre en place des ateliers
on nous a refusé tous les projets ce qui
était la laïcité et j'ai commencé en
2012 et j'ai alerté en 2002 en interne
malheureusement on a dit que j'avais dès
que je disait n'importe quoi et besoins
et malheureusement je dis bien
malheureusement l'actualité m'a donné
raison
et n'oubliez pas un truc important quand
on parle de laïcité il ya un truc très
important n'oubliez pas qu'on a des
jeunes français qui sont partis
combattre en syrie et ça on oublie ça
c'est important
pourquoi ces jeunes sont partis parce
qu'effectivement parce qu'on a été lâche
on n'a rien
dir nicolas glières à la raison
d'habyarimana il faut impliquer
impérativement les parents d'élèves ont
complètement certains parents d'élèves
ne sont pas dans le jeu républicain
visiblement et puis les parents d'élèves
de façon générale doivent être impliqués
dont tout ce qui fait de leurs enfants
un citoyen du pays
ce n'est pas seulement un voeu pieux
c'est normal on est en france on
applique les règles du pays
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec tout
ça je suis fut militant donc je veux
dire que je combats régulièrement la
politique gouvernementale
bien sûr qu'on a le droit de contester
mais on doit élever ses enfants aussi
selon les valeurs du pays dans lequel on
vit voilà ça me paraît tout à fait
cohérent les parents d'élèves doivent
apprendre à leurs enfants le respect
d'autrui
doivent apprendre ou à leurs enfants
aussi
même s'ils sont croyants très croyant
que d'autre chose que leur croyance
existe et que la france perd mais que
d'autre chose que leur propre croyance
existe en ayant le droit d'exister sans
est brûlé vif sans subir l'inquisition
sans être égorgés ou je ne sais quelle
horrible supplice que de très nombreux
religieux ont inventé pour ceux qui ne
pensaient pas comme eux depuis la nuit
des temps
mais voilà les noirs on doit se faire ce
travail là merci beaucoup à vous à
l'école est clair enseignants membres
des stylos rouges merci à vous également
la diarrhée man la militante associative
et fondatrice de la brigade des mers